- Quand ils naissent ici,
ils sont bien plus à risque
d'être enlevés à leurs parents.
Car au pays, plus de la moitié
des enfants placés en famille
d'accueil sont autochtones.
Même s'ils représentent moins
de 10 % de la population.
C'est ce qu'a vécu Ashley Bach.
Prise dès sa naissance par les
services sociaux, elle a grandi
en Colombie-Britannique,
loin de sa communauté
du Nord de l'Ontario.
" Moi, je n'ai pas vraiment
de maison", dit-elle.
- Il faut que ça cesse.
- Pour compenser des dizaines de
milliers d'enfants comme Ashley,
arrachààà leur famille et
souvent à leur communauté,
Ottawa débloque une enveloppe
de 20 milliards de dollars.
Un montant sans précédent.
L'argi i i i sera versé
à chaque victime reste encore
à déterminer, mais Ottawa
s'engage à ce qu'il soit
d'au moins 40 000 $ par enfant.
Une petite somme quand on pense
l'ampleur des traumatismes,
croit ce avocat.
Me DAVID TAYLOR, avocat Société
de soutien à la famille des PN
- Être enlevé de sa famille, sa
communauté, être envoyé autre
part, c'est un événement majeur
et négatif dans la vie
des enfants.
- Le gouvernement fédéral va
dépenser un autre 20 milliards
pour réformer le système
de protection à l'enfance
et surtout financer des
initiatives qui pourraient aider
les parents autochtones à garder
leurs enfants à la maison.
Par exemple, des programmes
de lutte contre les dépendances
ou pour subvenir à des besoins
essentiels, comme le chauffage
et la nourriture.
GHISLAIN PICARD, chef, Assemblée
des Premières Nations du Qué
- La partie la plus importante,
sans doute, c'est vraiment
de s'assurer qu'il y aura
une implication des Premières
Nations dans la démarche.
- Pour le chef de l'assemblée
des premières nations du Québec,
l'entente de principe est
historique, même si elle
ne pourra pas réparertous les t.
- On vient de mettre un terme,
finalement, à un processus
au sein de nos communautés qui
s'étend sur au moi
décennies et plus et je pense
qu'on vient apporter très
certainement un niveau de
satisfaction, je dirais,
pour principalement les familles
qui ont été directement
impact
- Les différents groupes
autochtones et le gouvernement
fédérent qu'au-delà
de cette entente de principe,
un accord final, approuvé par
les tribunaux, sera conclu au
cours des prochains mois.
Pour le gouvernement Trudeau,
ce serait l'occasion de prouver
qu'au-delà de sa promesse d'une
réconciliation, il peut aussi
contribuer à des changements
concrets.
Ici Laurence Martin,
Radio-Canada Ottawa